from new mexico to new hampshire with a
quick stop in nebraska and don't forget
those trips to mexico and germany the
story of breaking bad and better call
saul reaches far beyond albuquerque and
we've got the whole timeline right here
although both breaking bad and better
call saul take place much later than
this the 1980s set up some important
events that take place later one of the
most important things that happens
during this time is the establishment of
the law firm hamlin hamlin and mcgill at
this time it is known simply as hamlin
and mcgill after chuck mcgill and george
m hanlon george's son howard has not yet
become a partner in the albuquerque
company meanwhile in the 1980s walter
white establishes gray matter
technologies with his friend and
colleague elliot schwartz the two worked
together in college and set up the
company after completing their thesis
the pair are later joined by gretchen
who walter dates for a time her family's
wealth leads to walter feeling inferior
and he breaks off the relationship and
sells his share in gray matter
technologies for just five thousand
dollars the company goes on to become a
multi-billion dollar enterprise and walt
forever nurses a grudge against elliott
and gretchen but little did i understand
that they were artfully maneuvering me
into leaving my own creation around the
same time gustavo fring and max arsenego
approached the cartel about forming a
potential partnership donaldio has max
killed by hector salamanca after being
angered by the two up-and-coming drug
dealers giving meth to his men as a way
of manipulating ellario into meeting
them this is a defining moment for gus
who vows to avenge his murdered partner
by any means necessary
jimmy mcgill later known as saul goodman
starts the 1990s by running a series of
scams with his friend marco the two con
men operate in cicero but jimmy is
arrested and later saved by his brother
chuck mcgill after facing possible jail
time of course there's a catch jimmy has
to agree to move to albuquerque and get
a job at hamline hamlin and mcgill just
tell me what to do
whatever it is i'll do it jimmy leaves
for new mexico with chuck and begins
working in the mail room of the law firm
for most of this time he is a model
employee and manages to stay out of
trouble in 1997 jimmy passes the bar
after studying in his spare time and
applies for a position at hamlin hamlin
and mcgill unbeknownst to jimmy at the
time chuck blocks this and jimmy leaves
to pursue a career as a lawyer on his
own between 1998 and 2002 jesse pinkman
attends j.p nguyen high school he is a
rather uninterested student and draws
the ire of walter white after he fails
his chemistry class
not long before the starter better call
saul matt ehrman trout is murdered by
corrupt police officers he had shown a
reluctance to take dirty money and only
accepted the cash after speaking to his
father mike ermantraut a dirty cop
himself fury and he would turn them in
matt's fellow officers killed him in an
ambush this prompts a furious response
from mike who quits the philadelphia
police department and kills the two men
responsible for murdering his son he
immediately leaves for albuquerque to be
close to his daughter-in-law and
granddaughter eventually mike starts
working as a parking lot attendant at
the albuquerque courthouse by 2001 chuck
mcgill begins experiencing a reportedly
unknown electromagnetic hypersensitivity
condition this seemingly starts after he
and his wife split up in divorce leading
some to believe that it may be a
psychological condition rather than a
physical one soon afterward chuck takes
an extended sabbatical from hamline
hamlin and mcgill so he can avoid all
electronics living in a home he is
gutted of wiring and devices
the first season of better call saul
begins in may 2002 with jimmy mcgill
attempting to represent the kettleman's
when craig kettleman is accused of
embezzlement the lawyer is tired of
being a public defender and wants to
start more lucrative work his schemes
eventually lead to him meeting nacho
varga and tuko salamanca thrusting the
character into the criminal world for
the first time
jimmy ultimately discovers that craig
kettleman did embezzle millions of
dollars and takes 30 thousand dollars to
keep quiet around this time he also
meets mike ermantrout and begins
speaking to him regularly especially
when it becomes clear that mike is
useful as a fixer and private
investigator after eventually managing
to convince the kettleman to accept a
plea deal he returns their money and
begins to specialize in elder law
during this time he discovers that the
nursing home sandpiper crossing is
overcharging its residence and starts
canvassing for a class action lawsuit
the campaign is successful and on the
strength of it he has offered a position
with davis in maine however he doesn't
last long in the safe and cushy
environment and chooses to get himself
fired elsewhere to help kim wexler get
back an important bank client he breaks
into chuck mcgill's house and changes
paperwork around the same time mike
begins working with nacho to try and get
rid of tuko which brings hector
salamanca into the fold eventually it
becomes obvious that it would benefit
everyone if hector is killed but mike is
stopped by a mysterious figure when he
is about to shoot him with a sniper
rifle
in the third season of better call saul
gustavo frank makes his first appearance
the fast food owner is actually a huge
drug distributor and is planning on
becoming the leading force north of the
border it's revealed that he is the one
who stopped mike from killing hector as
he has his own plans for the cartel
member seeing exactly how useful mike
can be gus offers to hire him full time
meanwhile nacho switches out hector's
medication and he suffers a serious
stroke losing the ability to talk and
move freely jimmy who is now operating
on his own once again is taken to court
by chuck the older brother wants to get
jimmy disbarred for his crimes but only
manages to get him suspended as a lawyer
by the bar association however during
the trial jimmy proves that chuck's
illness is mental and causes a
deterioration in his condition later
jimmy manages to get chuck's malpractice
insurance cancelled leaving chuck with
no opportunity to practice law even if
his condition does improve chuck kills
himself at the end of season 3 by
burning down his house with a gas
lantern
gus begins his efforts to take over the
drug business north of the border with
werner ziegler he begins constructing a
secret meth lab underneath the
laundromats he owns in an attempt to
control the drug trade he also pays for
a doctor to keep hector alive though he
ensures that the cartel leader won't
recover and will stay in his debilitated
condition working with mike gus forces
nacho to act as a double agent against
the salamancas and to get information on
lalo salamanca when he arrives in
albuquerque to oversee his family's
business mike and gus agree to remove
lalo from the equation so they can
continue unchallenged and neutralize the
salamancas permanently on the other hand
jimmy strikes out on his own once again
and changes his professional name wait
jimmy jimmy what
it's all good man after getting his law
license back he begins focusing on
working directly with criminals and is
soon recruited by lalo to represent
crazy eight and work directly with the
salamancas he later has to help get lalo
out of jail when he's arrested and
travels to the border to get a 7 million
bail money ambushed by unknown
assailants jimmy is almost killed until
mike saves his life and the two make it
back to albuquerque safely season 5 ends
in 2004 with kim convincing jimmy that
they need to take down howard hamlin
gus's plot to neutralize lalo culminates
in a daring late night raid on the
charming cyclopas mexican compound nacho
sets a fire in the kitchen as a
distraction then opens the back gate to
a squad of armed mercenaries and takes
off into the night the mercenaries gun
down nearly everyone in the compound but
lala was able to escape taking advantage
of the fact that everyone thinks he's
dead lalo sets out to prove that gus is
working against the cartel
nacho meanwhile becomes the most wanted
man on either side of the border as the
salamancas hunt him for betraying lalo
and gus cannot have him captured and
interrogated mike arranges for him to be
smuggled back stateside but nacho
understands that he's between a rock and
a hard place he gets mike's word that
his father won't be hurt and allows
himself to be turned over to the
salamancas rather than fully acquiesce
to gus's plan nacho gets the last word
in before shooting himself in the head
kim's plan to take down howard has two
goals to force a settlement in the
sandpiper retirement home lawsuit which
would give jimmy a hefty windfall thanks
to his finders fee and to punish howard
for his general attitude over the course
of the show what follows is an intricate
coordinated plan across summer 2004 to
make it appear as if howard is a drug
addict using planted bags of powder
disguises stolen cars and staged
photographs their plan works all too
well ruining howard's reputation with
colleagues like clifford maine and
sending him into an emotional tailspin
meanwhile lalo salamanca has spent the
week since the raid on his compound
traveling the world in secret to expose
gus spring he knows that gus made use of
a german engineering team the year
before to build something underneath an
industrial laundromat outside of town he
knows that nacho betrayed him on fring's
orders and he suspects that jimmy who
was introduced to him by nacho knows
more than he let on when they last spoke
the legal world and the cartel world
mostly exist separate from each other on
better call saul but in the season 6
episode plan and execution these worlds
collide as both howard and lalo arrive
at jimmy and kim's condo seeking answers
lalo has no patience for howard's side
of things however and shoots him within
seconds okay
stuck
lalo sends a traumatized kim on a
mission drive to gus springs house ring
the doorbell and gun down whoever
answers this is of course a suicide
mission whose intent is to distract gus
and his men so lalo can get inside the
laundromat and see what exactly is going
on however gus quickly realizes lalo's
plan and heads to the laundromat himself
only for lalo to get the drop on him at
gunpoint he forces gus to take him into
the under construction super lab where
gus is able to kill the lights and reach
a gun he had hidden away the two men
fire at each other in the dark but only
gus's bullet finds its mark lalo dies
with a smile on his face
that same night mike and his crew remove
howard's body and clean up jimmy's condo
as if the killing never even happened
howard and lalo are buried together
underneath the super lab floor never to
be found again and while jimmy is more
than willing to compartmentalize
howard's death and their complicity in
it kim is unable to do so she submits a
resignation from the new mexico bar
association and leaves jimmy the harm
that they cause others when they are
together is too great it can't be
justified by their love for each other
as kim packs boxes the episode fun and
games ends with a devastating flash
forward to 2005. one year later when we
see that without her jimmy has fully
embraced the amoral decadent lifestyle
of saul goodman
breaking bad is set in 2008 with the
show starting as walter white is
diagnosed with terminal lung cancer at
the age of 50. this prompts the high
school chemistry teacher to go on a ride
along with his brother-in-law dea agent
hank schroeder that's when he recognizes
his former student jesse pinkman and
sees an opportunity to partner up with
his former student to cook math to pay
his medical bills and leave something
for his family he approaches jesse and
they both agree to work together and
combine their talents chorality mirrored
images
right
active inactive
good bad while things don't exactly go
smoothly at first walter and jesse do
manage to successfully sell math and
soon begin cooking in an old rv out in
the desert the pair eventually run into
tuco salamanca and enter into a
partnership with him to distribute the
drugs as the relationship worsens they
eventually end up meeting hector
salamanca and are set to be killed by
tuko however hank arrives and
unknowingly saves the two rookie cooks
and kills tuko in a shootout
with tuko salamanca no longer a problem
walter and jesse have an opportunity to
expand and take over the role of
distributors jesse teams up with skinny
pete and badger to start selling them at
themselves and they see a good amount of
success at first jesse even develops an
undeserved reputation for being a
cold-blooded killer making it easier for
his gang to collect money from dealers
it changes in their personal
circumstances make things more difficult
for them to continue cooking math skylar
becomes increasingly suspicious of
walter and what he's doing in his spare
time when she discovers he has a second
phone she initially suspects he may be
having an affair eventually she
discovers that he has been lying about
getting money from his former business
partners to pay for his medical bills
around the same time jesse enters a
relationship with jane margulis and they
start using drugs regularly in need of a
lawyer to get badger off the hook after
a sting operation walter and jesse go to
saul goodman he's able to help them get
badger a lighter sentence when he is
arrested and comes up with a plan to
make their extra income seem legitimate
after some discussion he puts him in
contact with gustav fring and the
kingpin agrees to buy a shipment of meth
skylar leaves walt prompting him to try
and quit the drug business in an attempt
to fix his marriage gus is able to
convince him to work directly for him
giving walter a private underground lab
to work in jesse joins walter a few
weeks later and the pair continued to
cook meth on an industrial scale despite
some initial success the relationship
between gus walter and jesse soon falls
apart a series of decisions leads gus to
try and cut them out of his business but
they kill their potential replacement
saving them for at least a little while
in a moment of triumph gus finally
succeeds in getting his revenge on the
cartel taking mike and jesse south of
the border he poisons the leading
members of the gang effectively removing
all competition in the meth trade and
finally accomplishing his revenge when
he returns to albuquerque gus fires walt
and warns him to stay away from jesse
realizing that his life is in danger
walt tries to leave town with his family
but doesn't have enough money to pay for
everyone ultimately he resolves to kill
gus as a way of removing the threat
using gus's hatred of hector salamanca
against him walt assassinates gus using
a bomb strap to the old cartel member's
wheelchair along with jesse and mike
walt takes over what is left of the meth
business and becomes incredibly
successful they discover lydia rhodart
quail and gus's involvement with
madrigal after walter has mike and all
of his men killed to protect himself he
works with lydia to expand his
operations to europe even though
walter's business is thriving hank
discovers that he is the elusive
heisenberg and starts working to take it
down ultimately hank and steven gomez
are killed in a shootout with the
neo-nazi group that walter is working
with the group takes jesse hostage and
forces him to continue making meth for
them in captivity to avoid being
arrested walter flees to new hampshire
under a new identity for six months with
his death imminent from his returning
cancer walter goes back to albuquerque
kills lydia and the nazis and frees
jesse before succumbing to his wounds as
police arrive at the scene
before el camino the last time viewers
see jesse is when he's speeding away
from the nazi compound as police close
in the movie begins almost immediately
after this with jessie escaping to
skinny pete's house with the help of
badger and skinny pet he manages to
safely avoid the police and he heads to
todd's old apartment to try and scrape
together enough money to purchase a new
identity from ed the vacuum salesman he
finds himself 1800 short of the
necessary amount and ed is unwilling to
do the deal without full payment getting
the cash together proves difficult but
jesse is ultimately able to get the full
amount and then some jesse goes back to
ed and chooses to start a new life in
alaska
as part of the better call saul series
each season features a flash forward
showing jimmy in the present day living
under his new identity of gene togovic
located in omaha he works as a cinnabon
manager and is constantly nervous about
his former life being uncovered or
someone recognizing him still the former
lawyer clearly feels very attached to
saul goodman watching old commercials on
vhs jimmy's secret identity seems to
work perfectly and his new social
security number even holds up when he's
taken to the hospital after a suspected
heart attack however a cab driver
recognizes that men later confronts him
at the mall confirming that he knows he
is really sol goodman jimmy calls ed to
arrange another pickup and then changes
his mind saying that he will deal with
the issue himself
jimmy handles jeff the cab driver the
only way he knows how to with a good
old-fashioned con job using jeff's
elderly mother marion as leverage jimmy
makes jeff a proposition a one-time
introduction to the saul goodman style
criminal life by a heist of luxury goods
from the department store at the mall
where gene togovic works the heist goes
off almost perfectly and the success
gives jimmy a rush he hasn't felt in
months since leaving albuquerque after a
frustrating phone call to kim now living
in florida jimmy finds himself back in
the con man lifestyle running identity
theft scams with jeff and jeff's friend
buddy everything is going well for weeks
until a scam gone wrong lands jeff in
jail jimmy arranges for marion to post
his bail but when he arrives to take her
to the courthouse she confronts him with
saul goodman commercials she found
online i typed in conman and albuquerque
and up you popped
biggest day
jimmy flees the house with the police
hot on his tail
after divorcing jimmy and leaving new
mexico in 2005 kim spends the next
several years building a purposely bland
no opinion kind of life in central
florida when walter white's drug empire
finally collapses and makes national
news in early 2010 kim reaches out to
francesca saul's former receptionist to
make sure she's alright and jimmy is
still alive when jimmy finds out about
this in november 2010 he takes it as a
sign to reach out to kim himself that
phone call does not go well kim though
glad he is alive still wants nothing to
do with jimmy and thinks he should
confess everything and turn himself in
when he petulantly counters that maybe
she should be the one to confess kim
does exactly that traveling back to
albuquerque with a notarized confession
of the events that led up to howard's
death in 2004 she delivers one copy to
the district attorney's office and the
other to howard's widow cheryl but the
fact that there isn't any physical
evidence to back up her confession means
that it's unlikely she'll be tried in
criminal court however cheryl implies
that there's another pass she can take
to get revenge i could sue you in civil
court i could take everything you've got
nevertheless the act of confession seems
to awaken something in kim and when she
returns to florida she begins
volunteering at a local free legal aid
office
after fleeing marion's home omaha police
find gene hiding in a dumpster facing a
life sentence plus 190 years for his
many crimes as a member of the
heisenberg empire jimmy channels saw
goodman one last time acting as his own
attorney and claiming that his work for
walter white was made under duress the
possibility of a hung jury or mistrial
prompts a lead prosecutor to pitch a
plea deal in which jimmy would serve
less than eight years at a minimum
security prison at the hearing to
finalize the plea deal however jimmy has
one last trick up his sleeve inspired by
kim's willingness to confess to howard's
murder and bear the consequences he does
likewise admitting to the courts his
culpability in walt's criminal
activities as well as his own
culpability and chuck's suicide that 8
year sentence becomes 86 instead but
prison life seems to suit jimmy just
fine he bakes bread in the prison
cafeteria as if he were back at cinnabon
and he has a respect of his fellow
inmates and guards who all call him saul
kim visits pretending to be his lawyer
and the two share of forbidden
cigarettes one last time just as they
did in the first episode of the series
[Music]